right so how do we get angle alpha into
the picture it looks to me like the
easiest way to understand alpha is to
think about it again in the context of
triangle right so if you think of the
angle sum of now which triangle Street I
use I want the triangle which has theta
and has alpha Arena as well right so
there's theta and there's alpha right
so therefore what's what's this angle up
here yeah okay so I'm gonna I'm going to
write that all out okay because that's
going to be my bridge into this identity
because I want that an alpha plus theta
as well so I'll say let's see
theta plus alpha plus then angle CP oh
that's equal to PI radians because of
angle sum of a triangle namely that one
right so like you just told me
CP on its own will be PI minus those two
angles okay which is suspicious okay
okay good now have a look at that
triangle at the moment it's it's nothing
special
okay but they say at a particular point
right when when theta is equal to and I
think they say is a pilot - Oh am I am I
getting this map myself oh that's right
of course yes that is getting ahead of
myself I don't know what theories at the
moment which means that I can't assume
anything about this triangle right but
this identity that I've got has signs in
it right and I can use I can put signs
into any triangle not even not just
right angle triangle if I use the same
rule okay so let's let's let's do that
right now I've got sine alpha right I
can see sine alpha it will be opposite
what sine and I'll be so happy which is
one right which is fine it's okay
when you do the same rule you want to
make the sine rule this of it as obvious
or so
numbers until the very end right and
then this angle here right because again
it's going to allow me to use their
sneaky identity to get to here okay
so sine of angle CP Oh over there what's
it opposite
OC which we also know okay so you've got
your sine alpha on one your side of this
awkward angle in here pi minus alpha
plus T yeah on to huh
that's suspicious right now you do have
to show right this result is given so
you cannot just write it down because
you're like well I haven't shown
anything okay so the way I would say is
just to jog my memory I'm like look this
is my sign looks like between north and
pi okay I'm not gonna bother drawing the
rest because I don't need there is so if
I want alpha pastina is some angle okay
let's call that alpha plus theta okay
clearly sine of Pi minus that angle
which is pi minus that angle the side
values are the same
okay so therefore I can say this is sine
alpha I can say maybe I would put it
here but sine of pi minus some angle is
the same as sine of that angle right so
I can substitute that for sine of alpha
plus thea which is when I'm after over
two and then you just put the two of
your siding in there nothing
okay so right okay now I can't let's see
I need space but I can't remember too
much what am I gonna do
I'll try and go over here this is not so
important you can you sort of logic
behind it
okay part three
now we get given a specific value of
zero so we're given a particular instant
in time okay so it's when theta equals
2pi on - is that right yep and we're
we're asked to find where we asked to
find okay yeah we want the angular
velocity of this guy right in other
words how is he changing with respect to
time
okay signed after deep alpha on DT or if
I want to be I mean to follow this
convention I'm after alpha Donnie okay
so that's what I want to get to know
here is here is my one and only equation
that tells me anything about alpha and
how it changes okay so you need to
remember from here right feet is a
function of time it's changing alpha is
a function of time it's changing right
so you can deal with this line which has
alpha again I want to get to alpha dot
so clearly I'll need to differentiate
this okay it's a differentiate this now
remember that as a function of time feed
as a function of time so this whole
thing in here is another function of
time okay so in fact this whole thing is
really all with respect to time so I can
differentiate the whole thing with
respect to time okay so I've got this
sort of in my back pocket which I'm
going to use in a second I'm going to
differentiate everything with respect to
time and I like to put this down not
because it'll get you any marketers so
that I know what I'm doing right so I've
got two sine alpha alright let's give
this a go now because these are all
functions
this is chain rule isn't it okay so when
you differentiate this part here
you're differentiate the inside then you
do the outside these are both functions
I don't know what the functions are but
I know what their derivatives with
respect to time on it'll be alpha dot
and theta dot okay so that's good that's
what I'm after when I differentiate the
outside sign turns into
cause cause of alpha plus okay this -
I'll just pick it out the front it
doesn't matter
again it's chain rule because alpha is a
function so I'll get alpha dot and sign
turns into cos again okay that's good
alright so the fun okay cool so this is
really good because I've got alpha dots
in place right I've got theater dots but
I can get rid of theta dots because I
know what theta dot is right so let's do
it one step at a time I've got my outfit
up there I know what that is it's pine
and then when you go to here and you're
like hot on Syria it has a particular
value so this should be alpha plus pi/2
and then you've got okay now at this
point you kind of scratch your head and
you think um I've got these alpha dots
which I want and then I've got these
which I have to get rid of somehow okay
so you like how do i how do i get them
out of the picture okay well one step at
a time let's think about the easier one
first and one without the phase shift it
clawed nothing so how are you cos alpha
well if i want to know the value of that
then i need to know what alpha is right
or i need to know where it's situated
now the thing is this diagram right it's
a general diagram it's at any instant in
time but I have a particular instant in
time in mind so I will draw a diagram of
this for that value okay so it's going
to look like this I'm guessing um here's
my circle I've got my a B alright and
then he is too far isn't it I've got to
see and I'm going through the origin now
where is where is theta which should be
positive and the answer is it's this
angle in young and it's a right angle so
there's my feet up right there so now
I've got this triangle in here right but
I know that this right at the beginning
that's - this is the radius that's one
where's our far it's here so cos alpha
is adjacent on hypotenuse which using
Pythagoras is the square root of five
okay so early here I'm gonna have to
alpha dot and this will be 205 okay this
guy a little trickier to get rid of okay
but you can use some trig identities to
help you I'm gonna sort of skip ahead a
little bit because it's not too hard to
see that this should be for a memory I
think is a negative sine alpha okay
negative and you can go ahead and you
can use this same trick here so this one
no hold on you want to remember like
you've got when you when you face shift
this right by pi/2 radians how do you
turn that into sign because because
they're complementary right so I think
let me see if I remember this it's
whatever here cos of X right is sign of
the pylon to minus of X okay so what
I've got here is cos of X plus PI on to
so I'll add Punta de both sign of I on
to minus X plus PI on - no no wait it's
X was planning to in place of X so that
actually should be a - can you see that
I'll write it again with brackets help
you see it I'm substituting I'm actually
not just adding platitude about things
I'm substituting in for X ok so this is
PI R 2 minus X plus PI on - so it's the
substitution not just a phase shift
which is a bit different okay so I've
got cause off I'll start writing off
this down because I went out for alpha
plus pi/2 which equals sign of time to
you - part 2 cancels that's minus alpha
but sine is an odd function right so
therefore this is minus
okay so that's what I've done for you
with that and I know what sign offer is
because it's opposite one - yes sir I've
got alpha dot pi what did you say - one
on Route five that's that's gonna be a
full one route 5 and a confidante okay
so now let's see what shall I do I'll
want to play everything by root 5
cuz that's kind of a disaster right so
I've got alpha dot plus PI with a minus
sign at the front equals before alpha
dot yeah so let's rearrange a little bit
if I add I'll just expand this out
because that so if I add this to both
sides I get five alpha dot equals
negative PI so alpha dot equals negative
which by the way totally makes sense
because you're like oh it's getting
smaller
of course it's getting smaller it's
going it's going further around and this
particular insert in time it should be
when it gets to here it should start
shrinking right because I don't get to
here which is smaller so that's why it's
reducing